anyone is a fan of JG but I will already
know that he was he always felt like an
outsider in Great Britain he was brought
up in Shanghai
and he came to England he was 14 years
old in the mid fifties and it was very
depressed it was after the Second World
War
and he didn't recognize the country he'd
read about in books and so he always
felt outside it and became a great
analyst of the British experience of
socio-political economics and the class
system and our manners and our behavior
and our sense of humor and I think with
high rise and with his oven other novels
as well what he's doing is he's saying
he's taking a slice of British society
containing it in a very high-stakes
environment of a tower block which is
descending into chaos and examining who
we might become in that you know what
does it take for our British manners to
start eroding to start breaking down and
then who are we underneath that and he
and he always was very careful he said
I'm not saying this is who we are I'm
saying this is who we might be used to
say that Ballard used to say he was
holding a sign by the side of the road
as the traffic rushed past saying
caution bends ahead which I loved so
there's a certain sort of you know
ballad is the great interpreter of the
dystopian nightmare and that's what drew
me to honestly had so much fun making
this film with Ben and he's such a wise
man and he's such a kind man and he
wears his knowledge about film very
lightly and he's he's mischievous he's
got a really mischievous energy in terms
of what he's prepared to put on film I'm
a huge admirer of his other work
particularly of kill list and a field in
England I think the field in England is
a masterpiece
I watched it when I was out of the
country and it made me miss home that
could smell the rain it was interesting
yes sir Ben's great and he's impeccably
kind and egalitarian and he shoots fast
and I loved it we had a really good time
it felt like this film feels like an
indoor firework
and some people are frightened by that
and some people are thrilled by
you